it isn't like there's a need trader a
boy which is a Caribbean loom Jenny Duke
and I just got said anytime giant Destin
sucking movie anyway applies to the
caribbean dead men tell no tales Super
Bowl
extended TV spot we might actually see
Captain Jack in this trailer enough
[ __ ] around people
[Music]
hello bird flew away Wow
when I hear the trumpets man I'm over
rising out of the dress I'll bring my
buddy
[Music]
how do you think
I see a band crazy no grain
how to go MA Jack show up
[Music]
para la ley or annoyed buddy boy oh boy
that was pretty actually sweet I do not
like Pirates of the Caribbean 3 I hated
Pirates of the Caribbean for trailers
just love using Johnny Cash songs every
great trailer has an awesome Johnny Cash
song on it I notice they're usually like
western movies so the fact that this is
over a pirate film and it actually works
adds a really cool new tone to it I
wonder what the tone will be like I've
heard a lot of different things I've
heard they're trying to hearken a little
bit back more to the first one it's much
more fun adventurous pirates film but
this trailer adds that kind of serious
tone to it but the cinematography
doesn't look as like dark and creepy is
just the teaser trailer did it feels
like this could be filled with a lot of
fun actually which I'm really looking
forward to in the villains
I forgot javier bardem character name
and the people that he's supposed to be
like with it definitely does look like
the kind of villains that were in the
first Pirates of the Caribbean
Barbossa rocking that wig geoffrey rush
look at you my friend Barbosa is still a
pirate I know in the last one he wasn't
a pirate he just seems like he's still
kind of doing piratey things but he's
not really a pirate right now I'm trying
to find this one section where it looked
like it looked like Orlando Bloom was
back in the trailer but I can't so I
can't find that spot alright look I like
what they're doing with the marketing
behind this thus far the first teaser
they just really promote the the villain
and this one they're showing more of the
world that we're in right now there's
this very specific pirate out there he's
out to kind of spin really got to find
Jack even though you see Johnny Depp
sort of breeze like covered in mud he's
not kidding like a clearer picture of
Jack Sparrow there's still not giving
you that frame that screen shot you can
make where you see Captain Jack and he's
not covered up in something but I like
how there's still there building up Jack
Sparrow again which I appreciate because
after the fourth one I was like I don't
really care to see Jack Sparrow anymore
after the first fire so I was like he's
one of my favorite movie characters and
after the fourth on it like yeah
sick of doing it but I like how they're
rebuilding him up they're making you
just want to see more and more of him
because the trailer was really cool in
the sense that you don't see Johnny Depp
until like the very last couple seconds
of this trailer yet I was very much
cooked about a visual spectacle that we
were seeing throughout this trailer I
can't find it but I thought it's Orlando
Bloom for a split second oh yeah this is
the first part movie where it's shot by
two directors instead of just a solo
director these guys have a good track
record in terms of visual style it looks
pretty sweet to me this looks this looks
like it could start to see more what
they're saying when they harken back to
the first one and the first one were
five movies in and out of the first
floor I thought and the first one still
the best of me so arcing back to the
first one isn't exactly a bad golf right
now over the hill Turner all right gents
and ladies and kids an old man who watch
this channel the primary demographic of
this channel is 65 to 80 year old men
believe it or not I like to pose nude
for them occasionally you're new the
chal you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at the greg alba shout out to
my friend alex Romano who's sitting over
there
keeping me company so I'm not so lonely
I'm super bold a well everyone's out
partying she's 20 percent interested in
what I'm doing as I talked to you guys
it's great friendship